tensión y suspenso el resultado de las
elecciones presidenciales del 18 de
octubre marcará el destino de bolivia
durante los próximos cinco años un
economista de izquierda un historiador y
periodista moderado y un abogado
conservador con un fuerte discurso
religioso son los tres principales
candidatos se trata de luís arce ex
ministro de evo morales el ex presidente
carlos mesa y el ex líder cívico luis
fernando camacho estas elecciones son
históricas podrían ser el inicio de una
apertura democrática tras casi 14 años
de un gobierno socialista que tuvo a evo
morales a la cabeza sin embargo si luis
arce llega a ganar la izquierda
continuaría en el poder y morales aunque
refugiado en argentina seguiría teniendo
influencia sobre todo en los sectores
rurales e indígenas de bolivia una buena
el sistema político podría ser con un
momento socialismo gobernando desde la
izquierda y una comienza a dana de
derecha en la oposición
jeanine áñez quien estuvo al mando tras
la partida de morales se retiró de la
carrera a la presidencia dejando a
carlos mesas de comunidad ciudadana como
el rival clave de arce estamos confiados
esperando la decisión final de la gente
que creemos que va a montar para cerrar
el pasado de corrupción y autoritarismo
de despilfarro de abuso de poder del
proyecto del socialismo y va a abrir la
puerta a un nuevo periodo donde podamos
ejercitar la democracia la libertad y
entender los problemas reales de las
gentes los sondeos prevé en una segunda
vuelta para finales de noviembre pero el
ascenso de luís fernando camacho aumenta
el suspenso en las elecciones más
disputadas desde el retorno de la
democracia en 1982
los tres candidatos despiertan pasiones
y críticas en un proceso electoral sin
evo morales por primera vez en casi tres
lustros